[Music]
so recently president Trump as part of
diplomatic opening with North Korea
agreed to cancel or at least suspend for
for some time what he called us war
games with South Korea so training
exercises that the United States does
with its allies in the Pacific to
prepare to defend them potentially
against attacks and this shocked a lot
of people both because we've been doing
these exercises for many many years and
people feel in fact President Trump had
built up the potential threat from North
Korea persistently that said North Korea
is very dangerous and we need to be
ready to defend against North Korea now
he's saying we don't have to practice
anymore and lots of our other allies
with whom we engage in exercises in in
in the region not just with South Korea
are saying if the United States can so
blithely write-off its willingness and
commitment to to practice to show that
it's ready to defend us they're
wondering if they can trust the United
States US military exercises are one of
our main signals of commitment to defend
other countries to take care of these
countries that have we've made alliances
with over the years but these alliances
are very asymmetric alliances right
these alliances are really the United
States promised to defend these other
countries not that the Philippines are
going to come to fend the United States
if somebody ever attacks us it's a
one-sided agreement but to give the
Philippines confidence that we would
really defend them for years we have
said well look we always show up we do
these practice runs with you we help
train your militaries we make it easier
to operate together such that if we did
have to defend you we'd be in a position
to defend you and President Trump
without seeming to think through the
military implications or the political
signal that he was sending to our other
allies wept way ahead on making an
arrangement with North Korea that said
hey if it looks like North Korea is not
going to attack South
Kariya it'll make North Korea feel
better and more willing to make that
commitment if the United States doesn't
seem to practice something that the
North Koreans think involve the United
States preparing to attack North Korea
and so well I think it's actually
perfectly reasonable for the for the
other countries in Asia to believe
especially given the defensive oriented
trajectory of military technology that
they can defend themselves without
regular US military exercises and a
regular US commitment in the region
that's gonna take some preparation right
the other militaries in this region need
to adapt their technology investments
adapt their training programs prepare
themselves for a time when they're gonna
take care of more of their own defense
and president Trump seems to have just
sort of skipped over that and made a
very North Korea focused offer as
opposed to a broad offer understanding
its regional implications South Korea is
much more powerful than North Korea
South Korea the GDP is more than 30
times bigger if you think about just the
ability to use its wealth to spend to
buy equipment and prepare its military
to defend itself it's vastly greater
than North Korea's military capability
and South Korea's population is more
than twice as big they can mobilize to
be much bigger than North Korea
we're not leaving South Korea in the
lurch South Korea is very
technologically sophisticated country
with a capable government that can take
care of itself and there's a long
background capability of South Korea the
United States working together to
practice and prepare their militaries to
defend South Korea at the same time
North Korea's military North Korea has
not substantially invested in
conventional military capability in a
number of years they've been spending
all of their investment effectively on
their nuclear program because they have
understood that conventional capability
they were not going to be able to go on
the offense that's just been off the
table for them the
have a deterrent capability in the
threat to use artillery to attack Seoul
but that was not as good a deterrent
capability from their perspective as
having nuclear weapons would be and so
they've been relying on that
conventional artillery deterrent
capability to kind of get them through
to bridge through while their nuclear
program was gearing up but all of their
money went into their nuclear program
so North Korea's conventional forces are
simply not postured trained prepared to
go on the offense so we're not creating
an instant problem for South Korea by
suspending the war games we want to be
on the defense but in terms of the way
we train our military to fight and the
investments that we make in our military
the operational concepts that we use we
have an offensive operational concept
today so what we say is the way that we
want to defend our allies is by
threatening to attack to punish other
countries for attacking our friends so
we want to always have the ability to
project power and go on the offense
against countries like China so if we
actually got into a war where we had the
requirement to defend Japan or defend
Taiwan or defend any of our allies from
China our current military doctrine in
the United States says that we will fire
missiles and attack the Chinese homeland
as a way of defending our allies so we
have an offensive defense today but
given military technology and the
tremendous opportunities to make it hard
to project power into another country if
our strategic aims are truly defensive
if we want to defend Japan and defend
Taiwan we don't need an offensive
defense military technology is making it
easier for the United States to have a
defensive defense we should reshape our
military investment in our military
training and our military planning
around a defensive defense instead of an
offensive defense
[Music]